el senado chileno dio un importante paso
este miércoles para que el matrimonio
igualitario se convierta en una realidad
en el país al aprobar por 28 votos a
favor y 14 en contra el proyecto que
ahora deberá de ser discutido en la
cámara de diputados y que podría
enfrentar un tercer trámite antes de ser
eventualmente promulgado por el
presidente del gobierno sebastián piñera
viniera sorprendida todo su última
cuenta pública cuando el pasado 1 de
junio anunció que podría sumar gente a
este proyecto que durante años ha
dormido en el congreso y que fue
ingresado en el 2017 por el segundo
mandato de michelle bachelet esto es lo
más cerca que se ha estado de la
historia de chile de una igualdad
familiar para las parejas del mismo sexo
es un paso civilizatorio para el país
anunciaron desde la fundación igual es
una de las fundaciones para los derechos
de las personas de la diversidad sexual
que ha trabajado duramente para que este
proyecto se haga una realidad muchos de
los senadores que votaron a favor
argumentaron que
el hecho de que exista el matrimonio
igualitario haría a chile una sociedad
más civilizada y mucho más justa veremos
lo que pasa en las próximas semanas en
un plazo aproximado de un mes el
proyecto podría haber la luz